welcome to this video first round
coverage of the Zurich just challenge
2014 and this year they made it a
six-player or play all wrong Robin event
with the strongest line-up other in
terms of rating average we above 2800
this is quite nice food don't have that
too often and down yeah it's basically
the four top players from the Tata Steel
tournament so we have Aronian Nakamura
Quran and girl font and they are joined
by the world champion magnus carlsen at
the former world champion vishy anand
who returned to the normal tournament
arena after the match in chennai last
year so very very strong lineup and it
would be interesting to see how those
two fair after the break after the match
alright let's go to the first game now
can run playing white against kawana
note that they play an old yea rather
old um tabcontrol two hours for 40 moves
one hour for 20 and then not sure 10 or
15 minutes with an increment I actually
like this time control but it's getting
rarer nowadays ok and let's start we
have a goon felt by Kara wanna he's some
playing many openings but the green
father's one of his main lines and the
camera goes for slightly offbeat line
he's playing this check on a for Bishop
d7 now back to be three this is of
course a bit yeah almost identical to
the Russian line queen bee three there
are similarities but
the difference is of course the bishop
on this heaven which makes some lines
yeah fundamentally different of course
if you look at this like takes castles
and rubbish should be forced nah cameras
preference but if he would play a form
we see that the extra move Bishop d7
really changes things black can for
instance does not really like a 6b five
anymore because there is no fianchetto
of the bishop this does not make much
sense but the difference is that they
are very quickly be five ideas I think
even be five years of moves um Nakamura
is playing differently he's playing
Bishop f4 interesting move attacking c7
and try to provoke a reaction from black
that he does not really want to play the
plate c6 a bit surprising for me at
least I was more yeah thinking of
something like night a six and then see
5 but c6 is it seems to be okay if we
look at the game koala is getting a
decent position and we are playing e4
and then be five black of course needs
to get some activity on the queenside
with this awkward bishop on d7 he needs
to get going and he does quickly
attacking the white center note that
white occupies the center very typical
for the green felt but he is somewhat
behind in development especially look at
this the king is still only one and team
needs some a bishop move to allow
castling so um it's not all or great for
white and this attack on the center is
is substantial what should why do now
three for example takes material well it
takes on on c5 which is very sensible
but let's say for instance she takes on
b5 just too
to to show some possibilities what
should like do you can take on b5 and
take here but note that this move would
skewer to pieces and refute this idea
black however has some other options he
can't for example play Knight a 6
introducing night before and black is
really starting to get the substantially
development now I think night XP five is
not really a great idea if white tries
to prevent a night before with a three
for example black and take and now it's
a bit a bit annoying how do you actually
recapture a night recapture is answered
by night C 5 and black wins the e4 pawn
with a substantial edge draw Queen takes
it's not so we have an ugly move and
this is an instant reply and after Queen
takes Bishop takes black has a good
position note that this check is very
annoying situation for white so at the
end it boils down to the capture and now
night a six black of course wants to get
the pawn back and activate the night and
what happens now is pretty much forced
be 59 Teague's Queen moves to e3 at
first it looks a bit tricky but night
age five is a good one attacking the
exposed bishop and of course Queen
capture might take so it's not really
what what wide likes to do he opted for
Bishop g5 96 and now look T 1
Queenie idea the Queen cannot stay on
the D file for long no bishop age six
and according to my database this is a
new move this position has been played
before in a game where black was like
Quran Willem the top lid inva sorry the
top player from Vietnam is easier to
pronounce me then Vietnamese um in this
game Bishop e2 was played to the
opposite page six but Bishop exit h6
certainly makes sense exchanging the
bishop on g7 however if we look at this
now we see that black has activated his
Bishop here and he's got ideas to play
nigeria forum it really seems that black
does not have any particular problems
here my camera quickly changes some to
playing it safe Bishop d3 to e4 and so
on this was not possible here because
specially for check loses the Queen so
castles first and now we have a number
of trades and here even more pieces I
exchanged I think that this is a fairly
typical a game where one side in this
case White has played yeah with an early
aggression like those moves like a five
Bishop g5 Bishop h6 later but it sort of
yeah it didn't there there was no real
result of that was mostly trait and it
very often fizzles out to pretty much
nothing in the game after the good news
Queen a8g to was saying so why do you to
spend the move with f3 and now look da
and if Black gets this file it's pretty
clear that he has absolutely nothing to
fear in the game check we had a real
trade my auntie em black queen is
getting very active so why does deciding
to to exchange it yeah and this end game
should should really end in a draw there
is some precision needed and we see
become so f6 was necessary to get the
King involved but one point is that the
f6 pawned can be a bit weak with 94 so
we see that after the Kings are brought
to the center one problem is that if
black tries to a place h5 now if black
tries to play move like King b6 he
always has to watch out for this naija
for ideas so he takes the move to an
investor move with age 5 to prevent that
however we see now that after the King
invasion he needs to play precisely why
it is somewhat more active I think it
was easier to just have played king 26
but then don't think there is something
something terrible happening we have
some trades on the King side and black
is just active enough so that it can
stand this corners around here there's
absolutely no way to to see a forward
for white the night is always needed to
control C 4 so that black is not
activating and how does white make any
progress I think what nakamura got in
this game later here is the absolute
best what he couldn't what you can
achieve probably after some maneuvering
yeah we got this straight and why do we
win the fball but this is just a data to
theoretical position why cannot win with
the sole f-bomb down after a while
nakamura played f5 allowing the capture
if white would have tried on just to
show a bit of this let's say 94 let us
make some sense allowing the earth porn
to be pushed black play some King to
discipline yeah now let's say five even
as a drawn King important game with no
chances whatsoever so again to prevent
that you need to move the bishop sorry
the night let's say where the year yeah
like an even get the king over there's
absolutely no progress to be made here
so well I think a very correct drawn I
never if you look at this with a comp it
never goes away from from from an equal
assessment in the opening it has some
some ideas to improve but nothing
spectacular and later around here it
really feels like a very equal game so
drawn start for both lochaber and Cara
wanna okay um next game let's look at
Aronian against Arnold cannot always
struggled against aronian he has a very
very bad score against him some really
drastic losses so let's see what
happened in this game yeah aronia
opening who opens with one c4 he mixes
his moves see fall this time and uh non
signal it's his intention to
to play Queens gambit is not what is
usually doing but he also played this
against cars in the world championship
match there they played them played this
line the triangle where Carlton played
before and at the end of a she who lost
the crucial game the first game in the
match that he knows it was not due to
the opening though um yeah Aronian
however has a different idea he plays g3
and this leads to a position that is
also frequently reached from the red eye
opening with an idea 3d five g3 here
black has a principle choice he can
either keep the center try to hold it
with Bishop e7 and castles this can
easily transposed to the Catalan in fact
this is the most popular way to play it
also after this setup white can also
stay within ya ready waters with b3
Bishop e2 e3 which is an interesting
alternative to the Catalan because it
keeps more pieces on the bot the Catalan
the open catalano's dc4 we have seen
numerous times for example in the title
co tournament in white and there's
always some George tendencies about
those positions and black manages to
play c5 and sometimes fizzles out in a
draw the ratty is a bit more bit more
fighting but all this didn't materialize
because Allen took on c4 this is not
theoretically most respectable move
actually my bishop is heaven is also
scores of course respectable but d take
c4 is usually the argument against white
smooth order can you lay for check wants
to get it back now a six attending
the b5 expected note that a very typical
motive is that after a six the move a
form does not help at all black can
still play b5 it's very important motif
and of course this is leading to an
early disaster white loses some the
queen of all rock can choose what want
to lose um a4 is not helping and this
means that black will play b5 and c5
anyway um aronian place the Queen back
for prophylaxis the idea is to quickly
play a 4 in response to be five we see
the snow it plays first rugby 8 yeah be
five is also if we look at this instant
be five there is 95 so when the further
preparatory move this is needed would be
eight castles be five and now white is
ready to play a four note that after a
for my first reaction was wait what
about 95 but this is not really working
yeah those ideas are really ugly for
black he cannot do that what what he
played is perfectly all right Black is
just developing now there should be 7
p-3 yeah all this looks very normal and
c5 so let's um have a look at this
position maybe put this on the board the
moves before were fairly fairly normal
looking yeah this type of position is
well known and it's all a question about
those two points b5 and c5
are they securing black space on the
queenside are there just weak this is in
fact not easy to answer in the game here
it's however turned out that like had
some weaknesses on the queenside I can
show you how it continued drew Kade and
this allowed before and after this move
I'm not sure that black still get a
satisfactory game it's a bit tricky now
the problem is if those two pawns are
exchanged the resulting structure is
just a bit better for wipe the beep on
but being a passport is also weakness
and can be attacked by the rook for
example and this structure will emerge
now it's very difficult not to allow it
in fact on and try to prevent this the
structure with the exchange on c5 but it
wasn't really am it was a really good
position that he got played rook a 6e
for ya this is also very typical Bishop
back and night b3 and now we see the
pressure that is marching on the c5 porn
here in this position I learnt them yeah
it took a very young committal decision
and it's hard to tell if it's really
good decision and one important line
however is Queen a8 this is a line that
I analyzed a bit and the main point is
of course that this battery here against
the bishop makes it more difficult for y
to take on c5 however the capture is the
critical
let's check this takes and now black
takes on a five at first you think wait
isn't this good for black to two minor
pieces for the rook but that it's 94
which is very important attacking the
bishop on c6 yeah and the black guy only
has one now he needs to play the
backward night b8 that however after the
capture and d4 leads to dangerous pawns
so very interesting type of position
note that 'if I've d 594 and d6 black
has a very important resource it can
take on d6 and get the pawn this type of
position with a very strong knight on d4
in compensation for the exchange should
be a fairly ok for black I mean only
white can be better but with with the
material but it's very tricky and don't
don't really great for white rook e8
sorry Queenie ATM was an interesting
alternative maybe making it more
difficult he took on before and yeah
well this relies on a tactic and I'm not
sure that is really a good one ironia
just played Queen d2 intending to to get
the pawn on d4 back and if now black
plays nothing moves something yeah that
just keeps the position going let's say
oops let's say h 6 cm here h6 the black
just takes and what just takes and we
get to this position and now now we see
that the pawn move to e4 was controlling
involved e5 square and white is ready to
just plain I'd be to deform and capture
the port and the others is very very
difficult for black to prevent I don't
think he can really white will win upon
and probably the game later this is why
Island had something else planned he now
played the stunning piece sacrifice only
for I guess he already had envisioned
this idea when he took on before
otherwise that this capture didn't make
much sense but I don't really believe
that this leads to a good position for
black the problem is after that black
has he's got three pawns but these are
doubled and note that the b3 night is an
exceptionally strong blockade oh I don't
think that this is okay for black
reading white white should be better
it's it's tricky though still tricky if
we look at the further development of
the game we see that here um white
played a very interesting moves and a
good one good one he took on d5 this is
a decision that is not so easily yet
taken you give up your good fianchetto
bishop for night but it's still a good
move and the reason is that in this
concrete position black needs to take
with the pawn and now we have a
situation where a black ass well its got
three pawns now on the queenside while
we've got three against three on the
Kings side but look at those nights they
are absolutely ideally placed to block
eight the pawns this is just not a good
structure and yeah around here think why
this is very close to having a winning
position but it's still not so easy I
like this tricky defender he plays
through consi fall and try to activate
his pieces
yeah Queen to f5 and now intending to
even push the edge pawn here we go so
with time ticking down we cannot be sure
of the clock times though don't take
that too serious analyst trying to muddy
the waters with age five and a couple of
moves later in fact yeah we have some
traits here he had a chance to to really
put up more stubborn defense he could
have taken on c5 and this in fact has
some some tricky air points let's say
this and now deform is interesting to
get these exchanges going and to get
near the king the point is that if white
now tries to get the Queen's off to make
sure that you're not mated you can
generally get to to an end game of this
style check and it's not so clear that Y
is really winning that even if he gets
both pawns it can easily happen that at
the end you don't have the right pieces
to checkmate you only got two to two
nights and no bishop this is not helpful
and when waiting at the end the the
capture on c5 was probably a tougher
defense he played d for which after
night XD for didn't really lead to a
good end game we see what happens it's a
bit similar but not check yeah like this
now we have got rooks on the board and
this is of course a substantial
difference you get this straight and now
it's clear that white will win probably
both be pawns in the long run and he
managed to do that here's one pawn check
he needed to give up the f-bomb
and after some maneuvering yeah the King
needs to be centralized and now white
combines threats against the B porn and
the f porn and then the night is of
course the key piece the extra piece
that helps you windows end game white
always needs to be a precise yeah the
thing is he only has two pawns left and
if those get to get traded off of course
it's it's an immediate draw so it's
still necessary to play precisely yeah
not a very nice move but you cannot give
up the big bone check and check yeah
roni honest switching us attention to
the d6 square where the night has two
useful roles check yeah this bond went
away and now it's getting really need to
check completely winning end game and
also not difficult check again it's the
f7 porn where you chatter attack check
yeah and it just takes a while you need
to be to be patient just just no rush
you can slowly improve and find a setup
that really wins you the game the rook
on g7 ig5 a combination of those moves
will do the trick in in the game check
check we went we had this position and
here um well it is certainly a win in
the long run but here I made it a bit
more a bit
easier for uronian by playing Luke f2
and after the good moves look-see for
it's now a very easy win the point is
that there's a look at form as a threat
and it's very hard to hard to prevent
one point is that f6 rookie for check
check King f ed is losing innocently to
care for as this is check very easy yeah
and this means that after rooks afford
this position aren't resigned so very
good stuff aronia who also had an
excellent tata steel tournament which
only got a little bit yeah slightly
slightly spoiled by this loss in the in
the last round and get a back start for
the firm overall champion here by losing
losing this game it's not easy for me to
determine what really went wrong here
the opening has a very solid reputation
but when Aronian got to this point with
before plate I think black isn't slide
in slide trouble I mean it's very
difficult to to not drift into a serious
serious disadvantage em I think it's
clear that the P sacrifice was
insufficient but I'm not one hundred
percent positive how to defend better
here once you have this position you
probably need to go Queen ahead but
before they are of course also other are
the possibilities yeah well a good start
form aronia lesser it's obvious from the
result okay so we have the world
champion left and you still need to be I
need to get used to that a bit that let
garden is the world champion okay it's
been the number one for a number of
years before he got the title last year
but still it's something to get used to
after
Island being the world champion for 46
years almost more than six years really
it's probably slightly more than six
years ok we have Carlton against
girlfriend and girlfriend really had a
really bad tournament in the Netherlands
and he only I think he was out of it in
a 12 player fee dat was intense plays on
mines play that really it really wasn't
up to his usual standard so let's see
what what happened to you can also going
for c4 g6 and now he returns to a
defaulting we transpose to the gruene
fought where girl frontier opts form the
solid set up with c6 and d5 here black
has has many options he can also go form
somewhat sharper approach with d5 of
course this this type of setup which is
a bit more in spirit of the true goon
fraud where you give up the center for
the moment but a Tekkit with 96 e 5c 5
whatever and c6 is bit of us hybrid
between the grunt file and the Slav but
it is a very solid set up and probably
may be objectively one of the best
setups against this this line it's
important to note that black is really
threatening to take the pawn y term I
think should take care of the pawn a
move like castles can really be answered
by the capture and sometimes you don't
even get the ball back the serm can be a
problem so Queen a form an interesting
line and the line I didn't really know I
knew that that b3 is a move this I have
played myself on
biju also a possibility and there's of
course the exchange on d5 this is the
the easiest or the simplest way to play
to go for this type position where you
try to prove a very slight edge with the
extra tempo it's yeah probably not
leading to much but it has some some
some bite yeah Queen a form interesting
it covers the pawn and this is very
similar to queen bee three which is also
Ruth castles castles and now girl found
played an interesting and interesting
move he played night ft 7 back hmm yeah
the curious why would you move the piece
again yeah it's a very concrete idea
might be six to win the pot so wide the
reacts to that you retreated to c 2 and
T a girl phone plays a new move he had
this position before so I deserve I
guess a prepared novelty and when he
first had this against her off frazee
knee from France last year he took on c4
Queen takes the night b6 this is the
game present a girl font in played last
year in the Paris Saint Petersburg
tournament and also Queen takes up
squeeze eggs at e 5 also has been played
last year so it's a it's a known
position girl fans new ideas to just
drop the night back so this is a bit
curious because if you look at this
position it's a position where white has
just gained to move Quincy to for free
if you think of this position as
completely symmetrical on the King side
yeah both have fianchetto wood and so on
then you've got default
g5 c4 c6 Quincy do and it's White's move
again so white has gained the temple in
otherwise symmetrical position almost
only see four again c6 he has played
Quincy to and Bishop f4 so it's a yeah
not of his spectacular new idea to play
Knight f6 but certainly a play will move
it's not great this piece on the devil
and the position is still not so on
dynamic so that the temple counts and in
fact after Bishop f5 he of course
regains a move queen bee three queen bee
six and way again in a position where
it's um it's not a parent that black has
lost at any time sometimes in those
positions white plays c5 to gain space
I'm not sure that this nets so much here
black can just trade I can play Queen a6
is also interesting if you trade you
need to now decide what to do with your
bishop sometimes a good idea to really
give up the bishop and just just take on
b1 this type of position like this with
97 and so on is very very solid for
black the Queen side has sighs it's
basically closed and in the long run you
might play 5c 5 is a gap not leading to
much Carson once more he keeps pieces on
the board 92 94 yeah centralizing the
snide and here plate III yeah this movie
some game yeah providing the center with
some more sibility and it prepares an
upcoming idea and this is really
interesting now black now to exchanges
only three and place 9 a-6
so on how to assess this position I
think why does a bit better but only due
to what is playing now and this is just
wrong tanks on d5 and now plays g4 this
is an interesting an interesting
approach and the only one to really
inject some life to the position white
some claim to an edge can only be
related to the night on a 6 which is not
a particularly great piece and I mean
it's understandable you wanted to go to
the somewhat we can be four square but
this is still the problem okay g-form
yeah black now does not have much choice
it took it if you take on d oops if you
take on d to here then d 5 is hanging
and something like bishop is 6 and
routinely five it's not very comfortable
it's very one side at this position with
the d5 be no weakness modifiers reliably
protected I think this is really better
what girl from plenty took the poem and
now we have the straight and 92 yeah
well like now does not have much choice
he must protect the pawn for the time
being if he just allows the reCAPTCHA on
e4 like 94 95 whatever or maybe Bishop
takes to attack b7 it's a very one-sided
position so f5 makes sense keep it for
the moment and now f3 yeah if I this a
good response i think and if black takes
and now Knight takes we see that your
white has sacrificed upon but it's still
a position that I would very much prefer
to be wide simply because it's a much
easier to play white and
let's say night before I am to activate
this piece then 95 and ya round here
this is just an enormously strong piece
on g2 not easy at all for black to
defend I think what black probably needs
to do is to to take some very drastic
measures to to limit the danger taking
only five maybe and 93 something like
that but it's not not nice at all I
think if I was really better it closes
some important diagonal here why took
and now black takes which now gets to
materially quality but with the pawn on
e5 it blocks this bishop and it does not
allow Knight e5 so I think this was a an
okay defense rupee eight and now look a
five a very important resource
activating the loop making it possible
to use it here on the 5th ranked it of
course covers the pawn and keeps
pressure on him so here black is under
constant pressure and he had first
defense I think okay might be for my
deform b6 yeah that there is material
lost on the queenside but that's not the
end of the world you get this this bag
yeah and here here we have a critical
position really i think here black only
had one move and it's not easy at all to
play that i mean i would have been very
very luck tend to play the next move but
it seems to be the only one well girl
phone plays hmm it's not working but
only due to very precise move by cars
note that again that the clock times are
not right I think here um at least when
I was kibbutz in briefly during the game
people said that it was basically
reversed so girlfriend was down on time
like eight minutes and 27 for causes of
carbon had more time yeah what black
probably should have done here is to
take on d4 which is a very ugly move but
it seems to be the only move that
technically is working yeah this this is
what the computer recommends leading to
white edge but still is probably better
than what happened in the game it looks
terrible to give up the dark squared
bishop but yeah there are some some
defensive points this is one of them
yeah this is not good for white and
rupture g7 checking edge 8 yeah this of
course the same yeah White has a very
very funny response here rookies Evan
very difficult I mean this line to
calculate to to say the least but in a
in an analysis i need to show what is
probably the best way to play and this
it seems to seems to be the the most
dangerous check check these traits and
now this is the saying king of seven
yeah and this position white has an
extra pawn but it's a double porn but
he's got the fast strong and mine
with the bishop so why it is better not
clear if he should win maybe but it's
not not completely clear cut in the game
note that this line is is DPM 7 moves
and full of complicated resources Galvan
played the bishop edge fire which looks
completely innocent I mean normal move
but white has a very strong move now at
Carson managed to find many treat this
as a puzzle it's not easy absolutely not
okay I'm going to tell you the strong
mover a couple of seconds yeah the
strong move is 92 very strong the point
is that like now cannot take on c2
because of the moves bisciotti 5 check
yeah now it's easy this is easy
checkmate funny mate so black needs to
play rookie 6 and now the important
point is that why does not simply take
it but plays rook c1 this is much
stronger this is a pin anyway Black has
no way to to get out of it at the moment
and this attack is just very very
annoying now if black moves the the
night let's say here check this is
already check a force made checkmate and
this is a real problem the night cannot
move and the relatively best defense for
black is something like Bishop f3 which
is just leading to a position by why
does an exchange up yeah 92 is very
strong and black cannot take this means
that he really needs to do something
crazy now as it is a tech tend you
cannot move it anywhere you play g5 the
only move to keep the game going but
this leads to material losses now why
just takes it
and yeah how does how should black
defend now if he he played look g6 but
if black takes now this is the problem
double attack and therefore this is
probably probably forced yeah now it's
time to time to take stuff another pawn
yeah again we need to check night XE to
check hmm some funny motif see a ride
check checkmate very nice mate yeah this
is my rogue f drive was working all very
precisely calculated age 6 yeah and the
funny thing is in what can take that
again it's not a mistake age 6 black is
already busted he has no real defense
age 6 then he takes it yeah let's look
at yet another line note that the night
is also hanging here yeah he took on age
6 but what else is black supposed to do
again we can we can look at this but
it's still hopeless you know this was
played night before and yeah now wyd
centralizes the night 95 and he's got
two extra pawns he's got strong
centralized pieces and black has
problems with the skin with some precise
moves
cards managed to intensify the pressure
with galfond being a very low on time we
don't see it here the clocks but he was
very no one time yeah now the bishop is
also involved in the attack get after
King g7 rook f2 galfond resigned I think
he resides it didn't lose on time um
yeah and it's it's just it's just gone
night f5 check is an additional threat
and black really has no work no decent
moves if he takes on e7 there's root
checker check and well you lose through
something like that is entirely hopeless
so a win for cars and the loss for
galfond for really am yeah seems to be
still a bit under the weather from the
wagons in tournament but it's very
difficult sometimes in those games you
where exactly did he make a big mistake
I mean it's a it's a bit strange
sometimes and a causal Plata I think
almost a perfect game you cannot
criticize any of the movies all
completely logical make sense and and
and and beautifully calculated it's just
like how did it happen that this this
was coming and now black is under slight
pressure and it's easy to to break down
after that well what what he did is he
probably had here when you play that he
probably did some made some calculation
with a steak with 92 but yeah this are
all very very small details and you
cannot really say that drug often played
a bad game I mean okay he lost her it
probably wasn't satisfied and everything
but it's not like he was completely yeah
he was making obvious mistakes but
causal just played like completely to
the point each move so very strong play
by magnesium all right
thanks for watching the first round we
have the two favorites with wings and
let's see what what's going to happen
tomorrow I'm going to cover that as well
of course thanks for watching